hi guys how do you get rid of those ugly
pimples on your back also known as back
well that's what we're going to talk
about in this video let's get to it
i have
[Music]
all right guys so how do you get those
pimples on your back in the first place
well it works the same way as the
pimples you get on your face
dirt excess oil dead skin cells all
those things clog your pores
and then boom they turn into ugly
pimples that you don't want
so guys let me give you five tips to
prevent it
from happening in the first place and
also to get rid of the ones you already
got let's start with the first tip
don't wear clothes that are too tight on
your body
why because in the first place you will
sweat a lot more
and second it will trap that sweat and
dirt throughout the day that's that's on
your body already it will trap it
and it will go into the pores causing
you to get pimples
so number one wear loose fitting
clothes
[Music]
shower right after your workout if you
go to the gym
after you had your workout don't sit and
chat there with people go and shower
immediately to wash all the dirt and
sweat off because if you don't he's
gonna turn into pimples
and not just pimples on your back but
also on your face
[Music]
use the right body wash if you use the
wrong body wash it could make the acne
even worse
so when you go to the shower again take
your body wash
check out what is the ingredients and
don't use it
if it's got denatured alcohol menthol
men mint eucalyptus lavender or
silver now this might not be a problem
for
everyone but it will be for a lot of
guys out there especially men with
sensitive
skin because these ingredients will
irritate your skin
making the redness and oiliness of your
skin even worse
causing acne so instead
use a good body wash with acne fighting
ingredients
in them like benzoyl peroxide and
salicylic acid
why because they kill the bacteria they
unclog your pores
and prevent future breakouts i'll add a
few great options for you in the video
description down below
that you can check out
[Music]
check your medication yeah certain
medications can give you more
acne certain antidepressants for example
can give you more pimples
so test it out and if it gives you more
pimples or acne
go to your doctor and ask for an
alternative
shampoo and conditioner if you go and
take your shower
or bath whatever you prefer don't let
the shampoo especially conditioner
run down your neck onto your back
because it might clog your pores
giving you temples and very important if
you have long hair
whenever you can keep your hair off your
back
because especially in summertime it's
going to stay on your back you're hot
sweaty so that means more sweat more
dirt
and then it's going to clog your pores
now if you also have pimples
on your face and you wanna know how to
get rid of it watch this video here
and it's gonna help you out and i'll see
you there and if you haven't subscribed
yet
do it so you won't miss any of our next
videos cheers guys